[Music]
good morning millennials
happy thursday we are so close to the
weekend
hope everyone's having a fabulous
vacation
so close to relaxation so
close to sleeping in
so close to never setting an alarm
so close to not doing a full fat
so close to doing weekly episodes
so close to doing weekly plus patreon
reminder subscribe to our patreon
patreon.com 7.99 we'll get you a full
premium subscription which is five extra
episodes from us a month
podcast episodes vlog episodes and then
also access to our premium facebook
group for members only
the toast after dark speaking of premium
content though today's episode of the
redheads
went up i heard it was real like a real
thought provoking episode
it was a real thought provoking episode
it was a very thought-provoking book so
those vibes just
oozed out onto us and i hope that you're
if you're a redhead you make some time
to listen to it today or this weekend
you know it's never too late to become a
redhead
and thank you to all the redheads who
are out there currently you know there's
also
tons of new tnn content margaret joseph
says patty stenger on the podcast today
throwback
lauren elizabeth had the skinny
confidential on the podcast so all the
tnn shows are just
churning out premium content there's new
girls tonight with raven and alexis
and just head over to at toast news
network on instagram for all the updates
you need
yes every single update that you might
need um well i can't believe it's
thursday this week is
moving along quite nicely it really
zoomed right by which i genuinely
appreciated
yeah i appreciate as well we have so
much to talk about today because
real houses of beverly hills was just
really thought provoking
chefs italian chefs kiss plus so much
happened yesterday like really weird
[ __ ] in the news and i'm like
super um like excited to get into it
because like between jake paul and
there's all this e news drama
um it's gonna be a good show and you
guys deserve that
yeah you do deserve that you know who
else deserves that t.h.e.o being the
best
boy the best boy i woke up super late
because i was like having a dream at
nine in the morning
that my father-in-law and ramona singer
were going to jail together
and it's like if that doesn't sum up who
i am then i don't know what does
family and housewives like those are the
things that are important that's an
entertaining dream
yeah well it's because i was up all
night watching housewives and then i got
in bed with ben
like that's literally my life yeah no i
understand did you watch watch
live i did and i really enjoyed it i
have a lot of thoughts
i mean were you just absolutely dying
cackling when they were
addressing how the last time jerry
o'connell was on watchdogs live his
wi-fi [ __ ]
stunk so we went over to his neighbor's
house and he was like i would like to
thank the shapiro's of calabasas
for letting me use their wi-fi he still
had spotty service in comparison to
megan mccain and essie cupp
but it was fine it was better yeah but
they also do shows
yeah so they're like in a studio in
their house right she's on cnn
megan's on abc like they they have it
together yeah it worked out fine um
jerry is just so nice
and we spoke yesterday about i don't we
didn't understand like how and why he
was defending ellen but now i totally
get it
he doesn't want to see anyone that he
knows or likes or even doesn't like
be ganged up on and go down right and
that's what's so weird to me that he's
like ended up in the real housewives
universe because when he was giving his
hot takes in those games like agree or
disagree
i was literally disagreeing with
everything he said and i realized it's
because he is this like super nice guy
he's constantly choosing kindness yeah
he's he literally should fill in for
ellen like
he is like the epitome of kindness and i
wasn't agreeing with
any of his hot takes and just makes me
think how funny it is how he like ended
up commentating on
housewives which is like notoriously
catty and like you always take sides and
he literally does not take sides no but
he still has an answer for everything
yeah even though i wasn't agreeing with
like his answers no me neither i really
agreed with megan and essie so i was i
was
glad that they were there to balance it
out i actually when it comes to
housewives i agree with every single
thing meghan mccain has to say and i was
i appreciated her takes but i did not
agree with a lot of what essie cup had
to say
okay i agreed with pretty much every
single thing megan mccain had to say i
think there was one thing i didn't agree
with and i i can't remember
well she she very controversially said
that she thinks the greatest housewife
of all time is erica james you know what
so um i thought about i actually paused
the tv to think about what my answer
would be before
i heard their answers and i uh
erica jean wouldn't have been my answer
but for every reason megan said
she is among the ghosts she redefined
she really brought real housewives of
beverly hills into the 21st century
what dorite's bringing right now would
not be possible without erica not only
like
did they go from like having glam on
trips but like now everyone has personal
glam personal hair personal makeup and
it's like every look is a
look it's sickening i can't wait to get
into
the looks but i agreed with megan for
that reason my
goat would be bethany yes me too and i
was really surprised nobody said that
she is just the perfect her personality
is so perfect for house eyes when she's
in a fight she holds her own when she's
doing testimonials
they're so funny like she's rich like
they're i
i was shocked nobody said bethany
because that was my answer too yeah
and she has time after time she's
existed in in seasons that were like
star-studded and she has been the star
and she's also put franchises on her
back at times yeah
so it was a very interesting episode
where it was just like real housewives
canon which i love
yeah a canon i think you might like me
canon which by the way i wanted to talk
about nick cannon because
i feel like we spoke about him a lot and
then we like never and he like what got
washed out of the news cycle but
i've been like keeping up with him on
instagram and he like fasted for tish
above which i i didn't even do
he like he read barry weiss's book how
to fight anti-semitism like i just want
to say like that's how you do it and
that's
if you allow someone like the space to
grow within cancel culture like you get
in a cannon and i just think it's like a
interesting case study that we should
all be watching yeah because like
people have stopped talking about him
but he hasn't stopped educating himself
and learning and i'm like
like i wanted to be mad at him but like
i literally can't yeah no that's great
and i just i wanted to put it out there
because when you talk about the bed you
have to talk about the good i completely
agree so we have a fabulous show i think
we should dive in while also
i just wanted to give a shout out to our
lebanese toasters hope
everyone is okay the footage that is
coming out from this
bomb explosion explosion is so crazy and
so sad i saw a video
um of this like beautiful bride taking
her wedding pictures
outside like a few blocks away from the
explosion and
the videographer from the wedding that
got on camera like when the whole
street shook and they all went running
it was just like it just
puts into perspective like people were
just living their everyday lives it was
really really sad so
all of our lebanese toasters um we're
thinking of you
oh yeah i hope you're okay it's really
really scary yeah that is really scary
but without i digress yes it is time for
the fast five stories that you need to
know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast and that's true
jackie but
may i sure oh she was picked that up on
the mic my stomach is making this weird
sound i think it's my rdh acting up
maybe you should go to the bathroom
or read the ad i think it's my rda
tracking app yeah
well there's always policy genius for
when your rdh flares up
policy genius saves their home and auto
customers an average of one thousand one
hundred and twenty seven dollars a year
by shopping top rated insurers all in
one place
if you're thinking eleven thousand two
hundred seven seven dollars is a weirdly
specific amount you're right
but they crunch the numbers and that's
just what it is crunching numbers is one
of the things policy genius does best
their insurance marketplace makes it
easy to compare rates from the top home
and auto insurance companies
to find you the best price here's how it
works all you have to do is head to
policygenius.com and answer a few quick
questions about yourself and your
property
after that policy genius does all the
work they'll compare your existing
policy against others in the market to
make sure you're getting the right
coverage at the best possible price
if policy genius finds a better rate
than what you're currently paying
they'll get it switched for you for free
it's the kind of service that has earned
policy genius a five-star rating across
1600 reviews
on trustpilot and google so if you're a
homeowner head to policygenius.com right
now to get started
they've saved their home and auto
insurance customers an average of one
thousand one hundred and twenty seven
dollars a year
that knows that's a weirdly specific
amount but that's exactly the amount of
money they could save you
so head over to policygenius.com right
now to get started
why are you wasting money on insurance
like get it together love it
um also i remember that sc cup said that
vicki gumbelson was her goat and
that's why i didn't agree with her
that's when i knew we were on different
planets but tpg
who is like a housewives encyclopedia
like ourselves
he really also believes in vicki the
power of vicki gundlesen and her being
the top housewife
and i don't discredit him as you know a
housewife's historian but it does make
me you know look at him differently
yeah i think based on the facts like
sure she's the goat because she's the
first and the longest
but not anymore ramona's the first and
longest yeah not anymore
okay first story firearms were seized in
an fbi raid at youtube star jake paul's
home
federal agents recovered a cash cachet
of firearms from controversial youtube
star jake paul is at prom store dress
a prom dress store cachet
oh okay so they went to the prom dress
store at jake paul
um in his la mansion following a raid
there on wednesday or according
to a report authorities were seen
seizing several firearms including a
long gun propped up against a hot tub in
the backyard
from 23 year old paul's property in
calabasas early wednesday news station
kabc tv reported
authorities were also spotted leaving
the home in an armored swat truck
and a dark van as well as a truck with
several agents wearing military fatigues
riding in the back the l.a times
reported the fbi confirmed
it had obtained search warrants for the
property though the nature of the
investigation is unclear abc reported
no arrests were planned i mean
this is maybe the craziest story i've
ever heard first of all just when i
heard that the fbi
were raiding jake paul's house i'm like
for the fbi that's different than just
like the local police it's the fbi
that means like there has they've been
tracking him it's like when you see a
documentary
yeah trying to get out like like in
macmillan's they're trying to get all
the pieces together
they finally get the warrant and now
it's time for the raid like a lot of
work went in
he has been on their radar yes four
months yes so when i heard it was the
fbi i was shook
then when i saw pictures of like the
neighborhood
from just like regular people standing
outside their houses taking pictures of
the types of
trucks and the types of things that
people were wearing they call it a small
militia like they were literally wearing
it was like a tank
so it's like what the [ __ ] is going on
in jake paul's house
and then the more i thought about it
like because i kept seeing like
helicopter footage of
um his house and i'm like
he lives like a king and it started not
to add up because if
i never really thought about it but jake
paul
lives in my mind at like the same level
of wealth as like
jeffree star but we are very aware of
like what makes jeffree star
money like his youtube channel his
cosmetics company
he invests he's an investor in like a
big pot business he owns real estate
around the world
so it's like when you think about it
it's like how does this real how does
this youtuber have so much money
he explains it to us like jeffree star's
wealth makes sense to me in a lot of
ways but then the more i thought about
it jake paul's wealth makes no sense to
me like yes he has a
successful youtube channel and he um
has merch that doesn't get you a mansion
in calabasas like not even close
so you might have other endeavors as
well that not that i'm aware
but you're a stan of jeffrey so you know
all of his
like you watch the documentary if jake
paul sat down and told you everything
he's invested in you wouldn't have
watched that video he did have a
documentary with shane dawson did you
watch it
yes and it wasn't really about business
it was about like how he became the most
hated man in america
and it kind of softened him up but now
it's just got me thinking a lot about
his finances is what i'm trying to say
because like the house
did not fit the job description you're
saying something right and according to
the blinds which
you know the blinds can be off but this
is an anti-blind they say he's like the
biggest drug dealer in l.a
and he's also connected to like
allegedly
allegedly allegedly connected to porn
allegedly that actually does make sense
fiscally and also why the fbi would get
involved
and why he might have [ __ ] rifles in
his backyard like they weren't just guns
like they were literally
muskets like they were huge like it was
american revolution type [ __ ] like
what 23 year old youtuber needs that
yeah
i don't know but a 23 year old alleged
drug dealer
might need them that's all i'm saying
okay yeah that was my thought process
okay um if you take the blinds out of it
so far this story doesn't give us that
much information aside from the firearms
that were confiscated perhaps like
there it was an illegal right but i
don't think the fbi shows up at
someone's house who buys guns illegally
like i think that's a local sheriff's
department thing in waco they do
oh interesting in waco they do i mean
not that it's only but i did only see
three guns like i don't think the fbi
like travels with their tank
to see three guns i completely agree
there's something more to this story
obviously i think we will find out soon
but we don't know right now
but i think this is a much bigger story
yeah that will develop
over time and eventually we'll get a
documentary about it but this is just
day one story i could see like
where this ends and i see jake paul in
jail really yeah
the fbi doesn't just come to your house
for nothing like it's such a big deal
it's not like the even if the police
invaded your home sorry invaded is not
the right word
raided your home that's a huge deal but
doesn't mean you go to jail
the fbi that means they got you already
this is a case for the fbi
and chris jenner thankfully lives nearby
yeah
it's just crazy yeah it's very very
crazy we will keep you posted but that
is the extent of the story
right now yeah it's also interesting
he's
he's just been like in it you know and
it really
it gets my mind moving because the paul
brothers are so interesting whereas like
they
bust on the scene as [ __ ] animals
like literally like they were like
prankster and like just like
i hate that [ __ ] and then obviously it
all came to a head with the
logan paul video that just kind of took
the world by storm really the
one of the first early cancellations
yeah
in our in our realm yes but he recovered
nicely and i feel like he's actually
i thought like grown up a lot and i
don't even associate him with jake
anymore like
he's really like an adult and he's i
still think he's cute
but now it's like what what is the
association are they friends i needed an
update
are they in business together like where
where did we land with the paul brothers
relationship
and jake was the one that got married
right to tana mojo
and we need to hear from her logan's the
one with the podcast
impulsive yeah that's very popular yeah
okay interesting yeah it seems like
they're on different tracks
yeah no pod i want to be with the
podcaster so i actually feel
like logan's hands maybe this is just me
being naive like might be cleaning all
this
because i just really like believe in
his growth like over the last few years
logan's name is not in these stories
right no but it's just it's crazy it's
crazy we will
keep you posted i just i need more
information i'm so curious
i know and it's so hard not to speculate
i know you know
and just like make things up of rumors
that you've heard okay i i
i'm not making it up i heard it from
entities no no i'm not saying that's
what you just said i'm saying we could
sit here and be like maybe it is maybe
it's not right
but we just got to wait yeah wait and
see
do you think it has anything to do with
he's been like throwing huge ragers at
his house during cobit and people
apparently
got coveted at the party and he says
he's not going to stop throwing parties
would the fbi invade your home for that
i do not think so
me neither the mayor of la or the
governor or something said that
he would start cutting off power and
water to houses that were throwing
parties
which is savvy so i think that's their
level of intrusion it's the governor's
jurisdiction
it's not the fbi that is not a case for
the fbi i'm like that's a little
crazy but we're living in crazy time so
yeah we are living in crazy times but i
do think that that is
not the reason yeah that's not the
reason we'll report that next month
yeah literally okay next story another
crazy
story like on the back of a story we
reported on in january
and now e news pop of the morning and in
the room
are canceled amid greater nbc universal
restructure
can i tell you on my timehop today i
literally had a screenshot of the news
story because i posted it on our
instagram it's literally one year to the
day
like so a year ago today they announced
that e news was moving to new york new
york with a slate of morning show
programming top of the morning those
shows premiered in january
that's crazy of this year yeah they were
on until
march i don't think that they ever did a
virtual edition of e news or
pop of the morning and now they're gone
to me this is
i mean you have this conversation i
think like once a year about how enews
is the weirdest
network because in a lot of ways okay e
is the network
oh yeah sorry news is a a program an
institution i think when a lot of people
saw the story they're like the network
is getting canceled what about
kardashians yeah what about all of these
shows yeah yeah yeah
this this e news 7 and 11 p.m which is
what we grew up with that show was
canceled they had moved it to the
morning but now it's cancelled
pop of the morning is canceled that was
with liliana
scott scott and victor cruz
canceled and in the room which is the
jason kennedy like we're going in your
bedroom celebrities
show yeah i i think that's the right
decision
but sorry i i misspoke but what i meant
to say is like we have this conversation
all the time where it's like in a lot of
ways
e as a network is like the coolest
network like they have kardashians they
do all the red carpet
um daily pop has really become like a
cornerstone of a lot of people's
mornings
and they have morgan stewart and justin
like it's so cool in a lot of ways
but in so many ways it is like the
loseriest network they can never get
their programming right
they're constantly launching shows and
just when you think they've got it right
lady gang
they don't get a second season like they
they just like
can never get it right when they they
should be they're like the pop culture
network like
they should be getting it right all the
time and not only are they not getting
it right all the time they're getting it
wrong
almost every time yeah and what is even
more
that confounds this situation is the
fact that the e-news instagram
has 15 million followers it is the go-to
place for
breaking pop culture news every outlet
wants to be like e-news
and they can't like leverage
that instagram collateral into
ratings on the program that the account
is named after
they're gonna have to change the name of
that account because the online i think
yeah that's what i think their twitter
e-entertainment like yeah so it's the
networks account yeah
if you could put an exclamation point in
an instagram that would just be
exclamation point
yeah it is really strange why they're
not able to make it work
also e news has been on the air for 30
years um
at seven as an evening show they did it
as a morning show for two months
and they just canceled the whole thing
like why not just like try going back to
the way that it was but also
because of coronavirus they're not doing
virtual shows i think that
you know they already had a lot of
back-to-back content that was repetitive
in the mornings because you got e-news
you had pop-up in the morning and then
you had daily pop
and it's all you know 10 stories right
so it's hard enough to do that when
you're in studio and splashy and
glamorous yeah this is when people are
filming from home so now that it's been
five months and those shows aren't on
the air like
yeah it's time to cancel that yeah but
it's just crazy that a 30-year
institution was taken down by
coronavirus
yeah even though i think it was
struggling before i think moving it to
new york and in the morning was
a terrible decision i think it was
really perfect and of course like when
ryan and juliana left like it left
a weird but like that like it was fine
when kat sadler was there but they just
didn't want to pay her like
it's just they did they ruined it on
purpose yeah it was good with jason
kennedy and kat sadler they were still
part of the original institution yeah
they had a lot of
good hosts coming in and out tanya rad
would have been perfect for the job yeah
terence jay hosted for a while
he was fabulous karissa used to like
host segments she's on daily pop
everybody has so much great talent there
aaron suri zuri
morgan nina justin like so much
great talent and it i mean it just goes
to show you that if morgan stewart is
not attached to your project like it
will not succeed or justin
or yeah no but the only remaining
program
our daily pop and nightly pop which
she's on yeah it's just
he news like real sorry e-network really
baffles me in so many ways because it's
just
it's like the network of our generation
in a lot of ways but it's also like so
[ __ ] lame
and i literally if i had to put a list
together of the all the shows that
they've
launched and canceled in the last three
years i think it would be like 20 shows
yeah and now i'm seeing i guess they are
using some like
footage that they have in their file
cabinet
because they're making these shows that
are like celebrity
game night like and like facts about
celebrities that you didn't know what
are they doing
i don't know they brought back each
hollywood story but then but they never
brought it back again
again and that was a good idea they
brought back the soup but she is coming
back because we said that should be an
easy show to film virtually you
literally come in in front of the green
screen it's one it's a one-man show it's
a one-man show so i think
that's coming back which will be good
but yeah i agree they like
go all in on things they don't give it
enough time to succeed busy phillips
lady gang that moment
they gave everyone once yeah no it's
like i really think she was maybe the
downfall of the network like
you're right they come up with these
grandiose ideas all the money
and then they don't give it you have to
give something so fresh
at least two seasons especially if it's
something that needs time to like
root with viewers and the lady game was
a podcast
turned into a tv show like that is
revolutionary things take time they
don't happen overnight and i
loved that joke i thought it was so well
done
i i was just like oh this is it this is
just one of those things that makes
sense yep it's
it's perfection it's timeless yeah but i
never would have guessed they don't even
give it a chance like to grow
so in a lot of ways like i do think they
should have canceled pop in the morning
like did you ever watch it it was
horrible like really
[ __ ] really terrible really um but at
the same time it's like
have some courage of your convictions
like you're making these big ideas like
stick with it
yeah and honestly like not to say that
it's
necessarily about us but there's just so
much entertainment for free like
so many podcasts that literally get more
viewership than a tv show like it's
crazy
and when it comes to pop culture when it
comes to housewives there's just so much
to choose from in terms of podcasts web
shows youtube shows like
really and it's free yeah who needs to
buy cable to
to find you know some host who may be
good at her job but nobody knows
like it's just they're not keeping up
with the time it's a different world i
agree but i do think that
they have things going for them that
podcasts or
free shows or the morning toast doesn't
have going for them they have the money
and they don't lean into it they have
the money they have the access to
celebrities they're part of nbc
universal they literally can get
any single guest on their show they do
these like i mean on when daily pop was
in studio they used to do like these
segments at the end that were like i
know like dumb like morning
shows like fitness but like they were so
funny
i mean you just have to invest in your
talent like and that's what upset me
about the cat saddler thing it's like
aside from like the whole gender pay gap
thing like
wouldn't you want to keep her happy like
she's good at her job yeah what's the
problem
and i feel like now maybe they do that
because i think they invest a lot in
justin
and karissa and morgan and they should
have been doing that from the very
beginning but
i'm just this story is upsetting because
of all the girls who like wanted to grow
up and like be
kat sadler and giuliana rancic like
what's your dream job now morgan stewart
oh true true yeah but it's true like
everyone's job
everyone's dream job growing up was to
be on e-news and
the dream is dead no i literally
remember his dad sitting in my intro to
communications class and it's like what
do you want to be and
literally every single girl was like i
want to be the next juliana rancic
yeah and honestly i i felt that i felt
that too and then i
realized that everybody else felt that
too and i was like oh i'm i'm not
competitive enough for this industry but
the thing is it's like
really anyone yes here i am anyone could
be juliana rancic like
she just she read from a teleprompter
not anyone can be morgan stewart like
okay
morgan stewart has charisma she has
passion she has uniqueness she has
nerves she has talent
okay i i hear what you're saying and i
do think there's a difference between
the two of them but i think
all of this goes to show that actually
not anyone can be giuliana that's true
and people think anyone can do this job
but she did the job for
so long and the show was so successful
and maybe you and i
don't see what is special about her but
she she had the chops yeah this is just
you know i'd love to hear what keltie
knight thinks about this you know she's
in the space she works on entertainment
tonight
and i just think it's so crazy and i
think it's a really big mistake to
cancel e news
i just think like them moving it was
weird but it's it's a cornerstone of
their network and it's
fabulous i know so many people like
growing up when me and my friends would
like have dinner after school like we
would just get home and turn on e-news
like
and i liked that it was at seven o'clock
and i think they just tried to be
everything they tried to be a morning
show they tried to be this they just
tried to be too much at once
when what they had was good yeah i think
that
i mean obviously they've made their
decision but i think it was way too
hasty i think that they should have
tried to bring back enus
in the evenings with and virtually now
so let's make do with what we have like
with some compelling digital host
who can make a great show there are so
many great digital creators who make
content for their youtube channels
using just you know final cut right
so i just don't think that they tried
hard enough no and it's like for as long
as we've been reporting on
pop culture like e-news has been
restructuring like when it when are they
going to land on something
yeah it's and it's g has been
restructuring sorry i'm so sorry
e-network has been restructuring and
it's like
where why do we still regard them as
like a cool network like they literally
can't get it together fashions
yeah and red carpet stuff like they just
they nail yeah
and they have they have good shows too
like total bellas and yes
but for every total bellas there's like
30 failed reality shows living lohan
yeah i mean that's like iconic but yes
there are 30 failed
reality shows except they have one
coming up with terry bradshaw and his
daughters do you see
no terry bradshaw's like a football
player legendary according to ben
and he like lives on a farm with his
like cute wife and their three blonde
daughters
and like one of them wants to get a boob
job now like it actually looks like a
fabulous show
they have literally been promoting it
for six months with the same like two
clips when is it coming out it's coming
soon
oh okay well it sounds really good yeah
no it does sound good so i'm sure it'll
be canceled in a year yep
anyways that's the latest tv news
next up cameron diaz is speaking out
saying she felt peace
walking away from her movie career to
take care of herself
i could never give you peace so
cameron diaz who never really opens up
for us to us but when she does we have
to dissect everything she's like not
technically famous anymore like she
retired
she's not working she's retired she's
not working she spoke to her good friend
gwyneth paltrow on wednesday for the
latest episode of in
goop health the sessions in which the
two discussed redirecting the course of
their lives
away from the glare of hollywood so
paltrow asked what did it feel like to
walk away from a movie career of that
magnitude
cameron's us mild and responded like
peace a peace in my soul because i was
finally taking care of myself
it's a strange thing to say i know a lot
of people won't understand it i know you
understand it
but it was so intense to work at that
level and be that public and put
yourself out there
there's a lot of energy coming at you at
all times when you're really visible as
an actor and doing press and putting
yourself out there
she described herself as being quote
sensitive to some energies that would
overwhelm her from time to time
when she was more active in the industry
she said
i've stopped and really looked at my
life when you're making a movie they own
you
you're there for 12 hours a day for
months on end you have no time for
anything else
i realized i handed off parts of my life
to all these other people i had to
basically take it back
and take responsibility for my own life
first of all i love that we're hearing
from her because
it is very when you think about it like
she did kind of disappear but it was
intentional like she didn't just fade
into irrelevancy like
she made the conscious choice to walk
away from arguably one of the biggest
like
movie careers of all time and it was
intentional and you never really heard
from her on why she made that decision
and
hearing her speak about it makes the
most sense yeah it makes the most sense
hearing her
talk about it with gweneth like just is
so beautiful because in a lot of ways
gwyneth has also
taken a step back she's redirected her
attentions from movies and being a
famous celebrity to being a business
owner which is a pretty work fabulous
yeah she said the only way to get her
into a project that you're working on is
for her to be sleeping with the director
because she only
really does stuff now that her husband
does which is so cute and ideal like
once you get to that place in your life
where you could just like make decisions
for yourself for sure but it's also nice
like when your husband is doing premium
content
as opposed to like if he was just doing
sadly art projects terrible
movies and totally had to be in them
yeah it just so happens like everything
he produces is like emmy award-winning
fantasticness
right but it doesn't hurt yeah no if he
was putting together like students that
means cream of the queen
that if he was putting together like
student films like i i don't know if she
would be as supportive
right exactly um but anyways this was
just a nice conversation
and i think it's a good um
[Music]
lesson i feel like we're always talking
about somebody's like how do they do it
like how
do how can you deal with like the weight
of the world on your shoulders and the
pressure and some people don't have like
the strength to walk away from it mm-hmm
you know who did walk away from it
though
tinsley mortimer yeah no she was taken
away in handcuffs she didn't necessarily
like walking no
she chose a life of love instead of oh
you know
yeah i don't know it's i guess yeah
it's on a much smaller scale than
cameron yes but it's just
the most recent example i can think of
that's
the same thing that like shifted her
attentions
it takes a lot to turn down like you
know the thing and the money
and doing those fashion shows yeah but
like it's not that hard to walk away
from it when like you're going to like a
rich man it's not like you're giving it
all up you know
he's going to help sustain her lifestyle
more so than the fame could
you're you're not giving up the money
but you're giving up the fame and i
think
fame is is a funny thing you know
because it's addicting
and you can't buy it nope and so when
you have it
it's like how do you give it up how do
you if you
can't get it back yeah it's a strong
person but she's given it up and i think
taking it back more
times in her life you know like she was
had that palm beach where she was kind
of irrelevant like
if she wanted it she could get it back
she has that just some people's names
i never forget i agree but i think after
this she's all out of chances
you never know some people are just
blessed like where does it i guess after
because where do you go after a real
housewives of new york i guess like once
her and scott get married like they
could be on marriage boot camp yeah oh
god yeah
where do you go after real housewives i
don't want to know yeah very sad
podcast oh yeah that's true um
but back to cameron diaz i just love her
and i want
really truly good things for her and if
she's happy then i'm happy even though
she like did retire but then she came
back once to do the other woman and then
she went back to retirement
she's a woman of chase yeah and i'm glad
that she did she did that for us like
thank you
that movie is so good that's another
content upper big one big one
okay next story some instagram drama
between
me gun kelly oh i saw and brian austin
green because
megyn kelly was just being like a cute
girlfriend posting her mans
and saying um so i need to get a quote
who posted the caption first she did
okay
are you sure she did with machine and
she said
achingly beautiful boy my heart is yours
which is like so megan kelly you know so
me gun kelly
then ryan austin green posted a carousel
of all of his
um children and said
achingly beautiful boys my heart is
yours
that's like so [ __ ] losery and a
little weird because like the love you
have for
a partner is not the same love you have
for your kids so like it's just like a
little gross
um but like what are you doing like stop
stop trying to stop megan kelly like and
and their happiness because they cannot
be stopped they cannot be stopped like
he already looked like
a big loser and now he looks like an
even bigger loser he is such a nerd
like trying to get her attention like
this is like i'm losing all respect
and it's like the public has chosen me
gun kelly
of course how can you not look at them
you've been officially
left in the dust yeah and just like
embrace it you know the harder you
fight like the further you fall yeah i
feel as though
he should be channeling his efforts
maybe into meeting someone else
acknowledging that it's over he's still
very handsome i could get someone i
think that he thinks like she's coming
home soon well they did have this like
tumultuous relationship where they were
together not
they were divorced but they were still
together they like always found their
way back to each other
and that can be a toxic mindset to be in
for so long and you you
forget that that eventually it will end
and i think it really for megan has
ended but for him it's just like another
bump in the road
he doesn't understand the power of me
gun kelly right no no once you go to me
gun
you never go back ever you never
go back no because once you really
embrace and feel the power of
machine gun kelly like how can you go
back to bright by the way i just thought
of something
megan fox loves a man with three names
machine gun kelly
brian austin green yeah she does she's
consistent
i just love megan fox like i just i know
that she's like just
in love she's like probably having so
much sex and like she's just so happy
after being with
what appears to be a real misery for a
while
totally just get it girl just hang out
with lala kent like i'm just
i'm living for her in this moment and i
hope she's embracing it and not letting
this petty instagram drama get her down
yeah like trying to like
grasp straws like drag her down with him
it's not going to happen
no gun kelly cannot be tamed they're too
strong right now
too strong the flame is is so hot it's
so hot
it'll it'll dwindle maybe become a
little kindling
as things do as things do but right now
it's peak flame
yes sorry brian okay fifth and final
story a little exciting news kylie
jenner reportedly has a cameo
in the new cardi b and meghan the
stallion video
i heard about this kylie jenner
reportedly makes a cameo appearance in a
new video from cardi b and meghan the
stallion for their song
[ __ ] debuting on friday tomorrow sources
told tmz that the video was shot the
week before megan was hanging with um
kylie jenner and rappy rapper tori lenez
after which megan was shot in the oh my
god
yes surgery that was a crazy story
that was crazy there's i've actually
been reading so much about megan the
stallion recently did you know that
she um she got herself back in college
and like literally before last year's
award show she was like doing a final
during her hair and makeup and then like
went
and um like performed to the grammys or
whatever it was so cool
i know i just like the more i learn
about her the more i really respect her
and by the way
so crazy about she got shot yeah
by who by tory and but they were just
hanging out with kylie
they were all together i don't know if
kylie was there for that part um
but page six reported that torrey lines
was the person who allegedly shot
megan and police arrested him on gun
possession charges that is insanely
scheduled to
appear in court in october and she's
like she's recovering from a gun wound
she's still releasing bangers you know
she really can do it all she can this
will be a great music video that's
exciting
kylie's like lifestyle was made for a
music video i'm so glad megan and
italian respects that and sees that
yeah and cardi b's there too oh right
right fabulosity
hopefully the music video drops tonight
yeah midnight right friday yeah midnight
i mean that's when the redheads episode
dropped
wow you guys are still on top of me i
should stop doing that actually because
then i'm like oh the episode just
dropped it's midnight and i want to hear
what everyone thinks
so i literally like can't go to sleep
until an hour and a half isn't that
right
and it's just like i just should wait
till 9am i agree
um okay let's dive into real housewives
of beverly hills our tv recap segment
fabulous episode we're still in rome the
ladies split
up um to do equally fun things i was
trying to think like which would i have
went on the ferrari thing was so lit
yeah i think i think i would have done i
know i would have gone shopping i know
let's be real
but i like to think i would have gone in
the ferraris especially if i didn't have
to drive myself
also if you think of like which group
you would have rather hung out with i
think i
would i love to read and that's who i
would have missed in the other group but
i think i would have rather been with
like garcelle
erica yeah you know what the only person
i wouldn't have wanted to be around is
kyle
yeah she's by the way she's totally
bothering me teddy was not on the scene
she's really bothering me she's you know
what
the way that i feel about this whole
situation has really shifted where at
first i was so obsessed i'm like is
brandy telling the truth is she is she
is she
and it's very clear given how poorly
denise is reacting and how she's
tangled in a web of lies it's very clear
that everything brandy said is true but
it doesn't even matter like i'm i feel
so sad for for denise she's obviously
like
mortified because in a lot of ways she's
been outed and she doesn't know how to
handle this and she keeps making up
weird lies like
brandi also said she slept with one of
you like that was just not true
but she's so deeply uncomfortable you
don't know about that
no i think everything denny said was
lying because she said she didn't talk
to brandy and then she said she did like
she's just in a mess of her own making
and
none of this really should have ever
come out and i get that teddy was upset
because she allegedly heard
denise said something about her dad like
i get that but to
air something so private to get justice
for this like little piece of gossip
is so not evenly matched up in any way
and i'm really disappointed in everyone
i'm disappointed in everyone
like there's so much to unpack here
first of all and jerry o'connell said
this last night
everybody is upset with the way that
kyle and rena and teddy
came with the information information to
denise
and on the one hand it's like yeah as
human beings someone should have given
her a heads up this didn't need to go
down in front of the whole group and
i personally think it didn't need to go
down at all right but if she had gotten
a text message like an hour before from
lisa gonna be like
this is coming up straight i think this
was a line that did not
need to be crossed but it was crossed
jerry o'connell said this is housewives
this is what happens this is what we do
but i think with these women
you can make that argument for other
franchises but with these women they
care so much about like they're really
they don't cross a line with each other
but also they care about how they look
on tv these are very
well respected women yes and what they
did and how they handled it makes them
look
terrible terrible in a lot of ways
they're so
unaware of like the larger conversation
around
what is being said which is like outing
someone without their permission like
they don't even see it as that they're
just so caught up in their own like
petty [ __ ]
and like wanting to make the show good
that it's really turned me off to a lot
of housewives that i previously liked
what really bothered me was when after
everything went down and by the way i
saw a funny tweet that was like which
room would you have gone to
uh garcelle denise garces like those are
my people
i feel like er in terms of who i don't
hold responsible
let's see who i do hold responsible
honestly is kyle teddy and lisa
agreed i don't know weird was someone
was saying like
this was not cool what they did what
teddy and rena did
and like they didn't mention kyle as if
like
blame has just been foisted but that's
kyle's like mo and that's why she stuck
around for so long
she's so involved but also leaves no
evidence like she's there's no trace
you can connect her to the problem but
not there's no paperwork
right so the next day kyle was like i
had so much anxiety last night i feel
terrible
when she orchestrated this whole thing
yeah and so i think she probably did
have anxiety and did feel terrible
because i think she's
not a bad person she realizes like the
situation that they're all in now but
she had two days to figure out
how to handle this information and she
thought of all the ways she could do it
and then chose the worst one
yeah um this episode just made me have
so much more respect for dorit
for a million different reasons like
aside from the looks which we have to
get into
but like her being like it's always
easier to go with the with the majority
like everyone's
it's like five people in one room three
people in another like which is dory
gonna go to like and
you know i really respect when someone
takes the road less traveled and she's
unequivocal in her support and her
friendship to denise and i respect that
so much yeah i respect a good friend and
she's being a very good friend and
i think sometimes it is about like is
this true or or is this not true but
sometimes a situation it really isn't
about that it's about
was this worth being repeated was this
ethical
and also now you were bringing in
so there's the rumor but then there's
also the fact that denise told a friend
something
talk some [ __ ] about her co-workers to a
friend that's not on the show
and now that's fair game too when when
it's not
i don't care what everyone tells their
friends in private about the women like
it how what you do on the show is what
you're held accountable for agreed it's
irrelevant it's irrelevant so that was
really annoying
what was also annoying and so strange
was sunstrack
um crying in the dolce gabbana store
that she didn't want to try on clothes
so don't take everyone shopping and
don't be so show-offy
like you that was so strange and by the
way i totally get it i [ __ ] hate
trying on clothes especially in front of
people and especially in front of
cameras like
i totally get it but don't make shopping
like your thing and then just stop
shopping
i don't know i found her to be really
relatable obviously that was kind of
weird i don't think we got enough
context
when she was sitting at the table
talking about how she put on a view and
everyone's like no you're beautiful and
she was like do you like when your
clothes are tight i don't think anybody
likes that feeling right
and i just i had a real soft spot for
her in that moment
i think she has these fabulous
connections she's a major shopper the
fact that they're going to messenger
close to her hotel for her to try
on just says everything and so i think
they had this sensational opportunity
we'll film
the girls love to shop and then she
realized like she needs to come out and
do a twirl
right and that's not who she is i think
she's really shy
shy and a little insecure and socially
awkward which we saw with the seats at
kyle's
party and i i just i understand it you
know what i think said a lot about her
was that she ended up telling denise
that she had heard that rumor about her
and brandy privately um she told her
that off camera
yeah which is like what you that's what
rina should have done
yes i really really like sutton i think
and it's funny they flashed back to
a conversation from the first in the car
with the crowd
and at the time it was so cringy but now
knowing her it's still a little cringy
and she was definitely like
hyped up for the show but i like her so
much now it took me so long
but it's cringy no matter what but she
has grown on me a lot and i also
understand
her more now and like she's actually
really shy and
she's not show off yet at all yeah even
though like
she confuses me in so many ways like her
at the table full of people being like
garcelle it really upset me when you
asked me how i got my money which by the
way i think it was weird when garcelle
said that but like
someone who's shy like doesn't do that
anymore and you don't want to talk about
how you
got your money you don't mention it
again in front of eight people and you
don't
just like if you really are so shy about
your money like she's obviously not
yeah shy about her money those boots
were heinous oh
it was a cute sweet gift hey sweet gift
and no
woman none of those women are wearing
[ __ ] hunter rain boots
if it's raining or denise she'll wear
them but she's
okay we need to talk about the looks
okay well
here's the thing i i'm very um
staunch in my belief that like erica
jane is the queen of looks and like
none of this would be possible without
erica jane she is the queen and i think
last week she won with the looks like
she totally outdid everyone
it saddens me to say that like i just i
think i needed to say that before i say
that dorite was the queen of looks
because it's so erica's thing like she
made it possible for everyone and
glam is so her and i love that she takes
risks and like the women are always
like some of the women are always like
making comments about her looks which is
so like such a losery thing to do really
thought that we were past that and then
someone made a comment like about her
that she looked like she was going to
plastic surgery
so much and i can feel how much it
bothers her it bothers me too because
it's like it's
it's an art it's a form of expression
and like even though i might not agree
with every single look put together like
i have respect for people
who take risks and i wear the same thing
every day but like i respect it while i
don't always love it
i have no choice but to respect it and i
agree making fun of someone's outfit
like i'll never forget how much fun
how much they made fun of her in berlin
for her total latex look
and her wig and it was like she was so
ahead of her time like she was so out of
her time
so before saying that i think dorit
absolutely nailed
this week's look in every like obviously
the big reveal at the end was
sensational but i think her lunch look
with kyle was
literally like my husband just died in
the in i'm inheriting his
billion dollar fortune her highlight her
sunglasses her hairpiece
gagging i i actually my jaw like
hit the floor at times and i realized
like she
is my personal style icon like if i
could have anyone's wardrobe it would be
hers
i love how she like styles like all
labels and logos together well you know
what's so interesting is that i don't
think she has a stylist like i think she
really does it because i think she has a
stylist
because she's stylish doesn't travel
with her no but they they pack the looks
before previously okay i think she does
have a stylist
i mean it's so sickening and it's so red
carpet in the hair
but what i was going to say was justine
marjon killer
kills it killer every look even the low
bun with the big black pony scratches my
favorite look
sickening sickening so while she did
look amazing i do have to say erica's
look wasn't my favorite
like of it was probably my least
favorite look eric has ever done but
again i respect her art so much and yeah
she's just expressing herself in
different ways also i'm starting to
see how like different they are because
sometimes i think doreen and erica could
just switch wardrobes and it would wow
but no erica really like goes for a th
it's very thematic and
dramatic yeah and dorit i don't know
what the word for
what her vibe is but she just goes in a
different direction
also it's different because literally
everything eric is wearing is a major
designer but you would never know she
doesn't really do
labels whereas like doritos like the
flashier the more ostentatious
the better yeah but like that's my vibe
no of course and they're
both equally good they both just they
bring so much to the show
just in watching them get ready and the
fact that they don't even mention it
anymore but erica always lends her glam
team to
lisa arena it's fascinating yeah
fascinating i think they also probably
just like getting ready together and
smelling the tea
um do you think that the 45-minute wait
for dreet's look was worth it
yeah of course but it is rude like while
we are filming a tv show it's also a
real trip with real girls and it's like
if they can all get down there and erica
can get down there
you can get down there too and i think
she likes to be the last one there to
make a spectacle of her look because i
think a lot of ways she wants to compete
at erica's level and i respect that like
she's very strategic about it it takes a
really like big
woman to go against her to try and
compete with erica and she's doing a
really great job totally
and i think that they're both winners
yeah i mean she looked so [ __ ]
sickening and insane even in like the
regular outfits like of course like the
big
gold and black blazer moment was
everything of the sort and her and erica
had the same hair and it was so funny
but even i
i actually enjoy like the more casual
looks more because they're more
impressive to me
like how she can be so dressed up and so
casual at the same time you know what
makes me sad to think about
when she goes back to her room and takes
her makeup off yeah
and like washes her hair like but you
know what and sometimes i feel that way
about
my if we go to dinner and i got doing my
makeup and it was like a 45 minute
dinner
i feel that way every day i put my
makeup on 30 minutes ago but like she is
giving us
i think if i were her like it's for the
television
of course i don't know if she would be
going to this level like it doesn't
matter how long they're actually out for
because we have these books forever
right they exist on television for
eternity
but as someone who does take a long time
to get ready myself personally
um i refuse to ever be late because of
it
and dorie should be starting 45 minutes
earlier i know but at the same time like
they pack so much into the day
and they have breakfast and then they
have a day activity and then they go
straight into the night
and it's like torture yeah also when
dorit and kyle were having lunch and
they were having that pasta and that
white wine and the sunglasses were like
reflecting each other
and dorit was serving the pasta to kyle
and for her like ordering an italian
like
sickening it was sickening it was this
episode like literally made me want to
buy a plane ticket and go to rome and it
made me want to go to rome in the exact
time
do you know what what month this is um
denise stopped filming with the girls in
december
so this is probably like october
fabulous i love a chili roam day and
you're wearing a nice coat outside it's
i feel like it's more fun to dress up
warm in rome oh for sure
um oh okay i had notes oh okay um
i wanna just make sure that so first of
all i just wanna say like i liked when
denise like on the second night like was
standing her ground
grade like everyone was just like so
thrown off guard even if she was feeling
lies like she was
i i like when she is very strong i think
that she's putting up with so much on
this trip like
for the way they talk about denise would
have thought she would have left the
dinner the night before i never looked
back but she showed up to ferraris
she showed up to dinner she's having
these tough conversations next week
maybe she walks out of dinner but by
then it's completely justified i was so
impressed with her waking up the next
morning and like having all those girls
come into her room and like talk about
it like i would
i would be furious mortified i probably
would have left also something that
occurred to me is kyle richards keeps
saying brandy's a lot of things but
she's not a liar
um and then i was thinking like okay so
was brandy telling the truth when she
said that kim was doing crystal meth in
the bathroom
also was brandy telling the truth when
she was saying that mauricio was like
having an affair
interesting very very interesting and
then i saw a clip on twitter that was
like
kyle saying when brandi was on the show
she was like brandi will just say
anything to get
right of course and so is is she
she's a liar when it fits kyle's
narrative and she's not a liar when it
doesn't right but like
don't make just blankets no that's a
very interesting um
point yeah and i and the thing is i
don't think brandy was lying
we need to talk about one more thing
based on the way she told the story like
i
my heart like completely like felt for
her there are rumors
that that conversation was filmed after
they got back from rome
and like faked i did think there was
something shady about the scene
not in that in the sense that it was
filmed
at a different time in the sense that it
was just so over produced and clearly
staged like randy's waiting in the car
but she's wearing a mic
like i don't know if i and the rumors
that i read on like literally some
thread
are not verified in any way and
i don't know if i believe it i don't i
didn't see anything like
evidence enough to make me believe it
and i don't think it would even really
change anything um
except it would prove that the women
didn't need to bring it out because it
hadn't been filmed yet and
it could have done denise a solid yeah i
just ignored it
not bringing it up yeah also the last
thing i want to talk about was rina's
conversation with denise
because i'm just finding brenda to be so
disappointing me too which is
really sad yeah it it is sad and um
oh when she said to denise like it's out
there it's like no it's not out there
yet
and it's not out there on the show and
even if it was in like daily mail and
life and style like you can still how
much stuff do we read about to read
right erica kyle that the women just
ignore
on the show oh yeah i mean like that
time in the bahamas someone was chasing
to read around the pool right and they
cut that out because it was never spoken
about again they did to read a solid
yeah so it's very interesting the more
you talk about
[ __ ] the worse it gets erica just time
after time being so
wise i don't know i just think um
i think everyone could have done denise
a solid and
at this point i just i i don't care if
it's true or not like it's true
she's handling it so poorly because she
doesn't know what to do she was
blindsided i feel bad for her
yeah i feel i feel bad for her too like
who wants to
be halfway around the world with like
these people who don't have your back
and
i agree lisa rinna is in her friendship
to denise is incredibly disappointing
yeah the funniest one when denise was
like aaron will apologize to you guys
for sure and
then she's like when not when he hears
what you guys did to me here
yeah but she handled that well it's like
in the grand scheme of things that aaron
think is like not a big deal yeah she's
very shrewd and
and so it comes so she also is
untruthful she says like she's kind of
fake and she says things that
she doesn't really mean but she knows
how to play the game
because you know in so many ways more so
than the other women
she views this as a job like she goes to
film days of our lives she goes to film
housewives like
i get that it's her playing herself but
i don't think she sees it as like a
i'm gonna open up and tell my story it's
like no i'm showing up to get my four
million dollars and then i'm going home
to take care of my kids
yeah and also everyone's like she
doesn't open up about her personal life
like
what are she talks about her kids she
talks about her husband like what what
are we missing no and it's like
not only that look what you did to her
when you found out something about her
that was really personal you [ __ ]
aired it like dirty laundry why would
she tell you [ __ ] anything
right also i was living for garcelle and
her shadiness like
in her confessionals when she said that
dreit's look was not worth 45 minute
wait it was though
i thought that it was but it was just
like she was just trying to be funny it
was just funny and i thought garcelle
when she showed up in that black tuxedo
dress with the pink
like um wings loved love she looked
fabulous and i thought she looked great
in the purple text she loves the tuxedo
purple tuxedo on their ferrari day yeah
um oh i saw it as pink really yeah
that's so funny
that's so strange yeah i mean maybe
we're just talking about the same color
but just describing it
she's like so shady and i love that
she's really exclusively shady at her
confessionals because she's very you
know
she's gonna have a lot to answer for at
the video but that's like
i mean that's interesting housewifery
yes um what she said about lisa rinna
and the dancing
yeah i was i wanted to bring that up i
thought that was weird like i whether i
agree with it or not is irrelevant i
just think like
don't talk about someone's kid's like
thing you know serena put her kids thing
on the show
i know i thought it was uh it was
an extremely like shady yeah but that's
how she feels
rihanna was like commenting on some
karen here instagram live saying that
she loved garcelle like ourselves
and was freaking out um another quick
housewives update is that they filmed
the real housewives of new york reunion
yesterday at
ohika castle stunning which is like an
iconic wedding venue it was where the
blank space music video was filmed
it's like where the house in royal pains
is like that tv show
um ramona was on instagram stories
complaining that sonia and luanne were
over an hour late
um but apparently it went so well luanne
said it was the best reunion she ever
did i mean there's only five of them so
it couldn't have taken that long
honestly
um but it was in person so i just can't
[ __ ] wait i can't
[ __ ] wait new york is on tonight
we'll be recapping it tomorrow for our
last show
daily show until september so reminder
of a few things
one my comedy special is available it's
called disgrace queen please watch it
two starting next week so tomorrow is
our last show where we'll be in studio
for about a month starting august 10th
we're going to be releasing weekly
episodes every wednesday until we return
september 14th or something like that um
so make sure you're subscribed to us on
youtube the videos
will not be available during the month
of august so spotify itunes all the
places
the third thing is that if you're going
to be missing us in october
oh my god in august i'm just like taking
an extended vacation
if you wish if you're going to be
missing us in august it would be a great
time for you to join as a patreon member
patreon is our membership program so
go to patreon.com morning toast you pay
7.99
a month to get five extra episodes from
jackie and i their podcast episodes
their video episodes their vlogs they
include family
because they're behind a paywall we had
a little bit more in depth a little bit
more behind the scenes
some bibis stuff last month we had tons
of fabulous episodes we had an interview
with olivia
post baby we had my closet clean out
we also if you we talk about house a
good amount on the show but if it's not
enough for you we did
two whole patreon episodes like
literally 100 minutes of content just
talking about
all the housewives from all the
different cities over the years yeah it
was really fabulous so there's
once you become a member you get access
to that month's five episodes but then
you also get access to all the episodes
we've ever done which is like over 200
now so
it'll really keep you busy during the
month where we're gone thank you guys
for giving us
this space the spot to breathe we
said it once while we'll say it again
this is in by no means permanent we will
be back
full every day back in studio we are
truly just taking the hiatus brighter
and better
yeah so thank you guys so much for
listening to the morning toast
millennial morning show where we deliver
the past life stories that you need to
know before you wake up and take a bite
out of your morning toast
every weekday monday through friday on
youtube so if you're watching us on
youtube please feel free to subscribe
and give this video a thumbs up
we're also available as a podcast
anywhere podcast can be found so it's
spotify itunes city or public radio i
heart radio cast box all the places
so ever you listen to podcasts find us
morning toast and leave a five star
review about a beautiful stunning and
smart we are we love you guys we'll see
you tomorrow for our final show
[Music]
goodbye
you